there is more intense heat and
potentially dangerous weather for
millions of Americans this weekend parts
of 28 states are under some sort of heat
advisory or warning this weekend that
includes a swath of the Northeast
stretching from Boston to Washington
where temperatures could hit Triple
digits for the first time in six years
here in New York hundreds of public and
free cooling centers are open giving
people a respite from the Heat and often
oppressive humidity during the hottest
parts of the day Elise Preston is at one
of the cooling centers in East Harlem
with more Elise good morning
Dana good morning to you this cooling
center that serves seniors is really
helping today here in New York
temperatures are expected to feel like
up to 99 degrees and volunteers here and
around the country are stepping in to
help people get through this heat wave
boots are on the ground to hand out
water in Phoenix where this month's
temperatures have averaged 106 degrees
American Rescue plan money pays for the
water would you like any cold water yes
tens of millions of Americans are under
heat advisories and warnings a signal
the country's most vulnerable are in
danger
we've had tough experiences where we see
folks who might have been living in
their car for a couple days just a
hundred yards away from the door to a
public cooling center but they didn't
know that that was an option for them
but even cooling centers are missing the
mark for many you found some cities were
better than others but across the board
seniors lacked access to cooling centers
yeah across this country across the
country Dr jehoon Zhang at the
University of North Carolina Chapel Hill
looked at 25 cities with cooling centers
and found only 11 percent of people over
65 lived within walking distance of a
center it was less than two percent in
Mesa Arizona Nashville Tennessee San
Jose and Fresno California it's very sad
because they are very very vulnerable to
heat waves than any other age groups
even making it to one nearby can be hard
work probably a half a block and I
almost fainted yeah I got a bad heart
an important reminder that extreme heat
can be dangerous and tragic as it was
for a mother who went to work at
Tallahassee Florida Hospice Center when
she walked out and finished her shift
she did discover that she had left her
child in the vehicle they immediately
called 9-1-1 you know when officers
arrived they discovered that
unfortunately the child was deceased
now this CDC warns more than 600 people
die in the U.S every year from extreme
heat and doctors say those deaths are
preventable they advise wearing
lightweight clothing and drinking plenty
of water Michelle
great advice Elise thank you